episode eight of my entry requirement series
this episode is all about the Netherlands
okay the details are very complicated
so if you are from outside of the eu
there is a travel ban
therefore you can't just go ahead and enter
that applies to us
because we left because of brexit
I'm not too sure
if we are a little bit of exemption
on that list
and we can still go in
but the rules to enter the Netherlands are
No.1 you need to be fully vaccinated No.2
you can enter whilst not being vaccinated
but you do need to have a recovery pass
you no longer need to do pcr test
or any type of test to enter
you can just go ahead and go
I hope that helps
and yeah make sure to follow for episode 9 bye